hey that wasn't me screaming moving on
let's get into the details of the
conjuring numbers specifically the
Annabelle storyline here's everything
you need to know before you go see
Annabelle comes home before we get into
the details in chronological order let's
answer the most obvious question who or
what is Annabelle it's a doll Lorraine
Warren explains in the latest film that
the doll is we can follow the spirits
the Annabelle films are a spinoff from
the conjuring so all films either
produced or directed by James Wan a
tacit to all of us early on is they have
a superhero universe why can we do that
in the horror wall they take place over
roughly 30 years in different parts of
the world all of the films centering
around demons or ghosts if you will
possessing human bodies and objects in
order to thrive these stories are based
off the real-life couple and Lorraine
Warren and their accounts as paranormal
investigators
the film Annabel creation a prequel to
Annabel it properly tells the story of
how the doll came to be possessed the
doll maker Samuel Mullins and his wife
Esther lose their daughter Annabel and a
terrible accident he prayed to see how a
girl again the contact started small she
wanted permission to move into the dog
we soon realized it wasn't our daughter
one day the presence became too strong
and it attacked mrs. Mullins 12 years
later the couple took in six girls and a
nun who became homeless after their
orphanage closed down Esther is
bedridden at this point and needs a
stairlift to move about the house
Paranormal Activity begins in the home
as Janice one of the girls came in
contact with the doll after they were
forbidden from entering Bea's old room
[Music]
Janice is hurt badly by the entity that
takes the shape of B and is no longer
able to walk this leaves her vulnerable
to be possessed by the demonic spirit
within Annabelle Janice is possessed by
the spirit and terrorizes the girls and
the nun fast forward through the movie
the police rescue the girls and Janice
is relocated to an orphanage in Santa
Monica where she's adopted by the
Higgins and now refers to herself as
Anabel twelve years later with the help
of her satanic cult member boyfriend she
takes out her parents all of this
happens next door to their neighbor Mia
form and that helps us segue and to
Annabelle in 1967 John formed gifts to
his wife Mia one of the limited-edition
Annabelle dolls that she is long admired
John next door I heard scream stay here
but took it out
go back inside it's not my son go back
inside call names right now and is
attacked by Annabelle Higgins and her
boyfriend John and the police arrived
during the struggle and kill the
boyfriend Annabelle Higgins kills
herself while holding the doll
Mia decides to get rid of the doll for
obvious reasons but despite the doll
being thrown out it continues to appear
in the forms home the doll even causes a
fire while on a stroll Mia goes into a
bookstore
the clerk evelyn tells her that the
presence in the doll wants her baby soul
you do what you have to do during
another attack Annabelle begins to
levitate but Mia realizes him a horned
demon his holiness this is the demon the
satanic cult worshipped Mia is ready to
sacrifice herself for her daughter
safety but instead evelyn takes her
place Annabelle disappears from being
beside Evelyn's body Lea is then found
safe and sound in her crib six months
later the forms have moved on and have
not seen Annabelle
this brings us to Annabelle comes home
don't your parents keep any creepy stuff
around you keep it all locked away in a
room so we're safe we catch up with the
Warrens who now have the Annabelle doll
in their possession why don't you tell
[Music]
so now you know and now you can go see
Annabelle comes home on June 26th